FRANK: Oh, look at the dog.
MIKE: Look at the size
of that barn back there!
FRANK: Wow!
[honks horn]
♪
JAY: Hello!
FRANK: Are you Jay?
JAY: I'm Jay.
MIKE: Hey, buddy.
FRANK: I'm Frank.
JAY: Nice to meet you.
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
Nice to meet you.
How're you doing?
JAY: Pretty good.
MIKE: Hey, talked
to Danielle on the phone?
You said you had...
JAY: Yes.
MIKE: ...the first
Stanley Steamer ever?
JAY: Yes.
MIKE: Is that it right there?
JAY: That's it right there.
You gotta step in
a little closer.
MIKE: Oh, my gosh!
FRANK: This is number one.
JAY: This is number one.
[Mike whistles]
JAY: This was found
in Albany, New York.
And it was found
by Edwin Battison,
who owned this house
and this property.
MIKE: Okay.
JAY: And everything
you're about to see today
is a one-person collection.
JAY: Edwin Battison
was very knowledgeable.
He was a bit of a curmudgeon,
but he would tell you things
that you had never
heard or realized before.
So I would call him a mentor,
if nothing else.
JAY: Before he died, we formed
a private museum, non-profit,
to take the core collection
and somehow preserve it.
JAY: The core collection are
the finest of the objects
in different fields: clocks,
watches, scientific equipment.
JAY: So we were looking
around for a museum
that might take it on
as part of their collection.
MIKE: Danielle said you have
some stuff you want to sell.
JAY: Would you like
to see what we have?
MIKE: Yeah, heck, yeah.
FRANK: Sure.
JAY: Come on this way.
FRANK: Alright.
MIKE: This is exactly
the kind of place
that I wanted to find
on the East Coast.
You just don't find original
authentic collections this large
anywhere else
in the country.
MIKE: Alright,
what do we got going on here?
Let's see that one.
Is there any colour
on the legs?
JAY: No...
MIKE: No, there's
no colour on the legs.
JAY: No, they've
been repainted.
MIKE: This table's been
here for a long time.
People made a living
standing at this table.
MIKE: People are always
looking for something
with a cast iron base,
industrial, overbuilt.
You know,
it's just very simple.
JAY: Fine, I'll sell it
to you for 200.
MIKE: Alright, we're doing 200.
JAY: Yep.
MIKE: Alright, very cool.
I like it.
MIKE: Collecting, I mean
obviously, you know,
it comes from the heart
and it's very personal
and everything.
But like this is like...
physical, physical work.
MIKE: I mean, this guy was not
afraid of buying anything
heavy or big.
FRANK: Alright, Jay.
This is a spool cabinet.
JAY: I understand.
FRANK: I mean...
I mean, I'm not knocking it down
or anything, but you know,
it is missing
a couple of the knobs.
The knobs are
very ornate too.
See the little
collar around them?
JAY: Yep, yep, yep.
FRANK: And this is cracked.
130.
JAY: Um...
It's a good piece.
I'd rather take 150 for it.
FRANK: Let's split it.
140.
And you can have the tools
and everything inside.
JAY: Okay.
FRANK: Deal?
JAY: It's a deal.
MIKE: So I've never met anybody
so dedicated to a collection
that they didn't
gather themselves.
The great thing that's happening
here is that Jay picked up
where Edwin left off, and he's
still carrying that torch.
FRANK: Jay...
MIKE: Appreciate you.
Good luck.
I enjoyed your passion.
JAY: Nice to see other
people appreciate it.
[honks horn]
MIKE: See ya, buddy!
Roll on!
JAY: Have a good one.
♪